المترجم: Sharaf Alkibsi
المدقّق: Anwar Dafa-Alla
(موسيقى)
♪♪ بدلنا ارض زراعتنا ،
وغرسنا بعض الشتلات ♪♪
♪♪ اهدتنا نكران الذات ،
سلبتنا حتى الادراك ♪♪
♪♪ امتصت ماء اراضينا ،
امتصت حتى النسمات♪♪
♪♪ كم ضاعت منا غايات،
وتهنا الاف المرات♪♪
♪♪ وشعور ندم اهدتنا ،
الهتنا عن صنع الذات ♪♪
♪♪ ستمر عليك اوقات،
ترجعك لتلك الساعات ♪♪
♪♪ وستخرج منك اهات،
وستذكر هذه الكلمات ♪♪
♪♪ حين ترى الارض تجف،
تسقيها دمعه حسرات ♪♪
(موسيقى)
♪♪ ما من بلد غُرست فيها،
حتى تركته الخيرات ♪♪
♪♪ لا يعقل ان نغمض اعيننا ،
او نبقي في سبات ♪♪
♪♪ يكفي ما شربت من ماء ،
يكفي ما اخذت من مال ♪♪
♪♪ لا نطلب اي محال ،
لا نحتاج لمعجزات ♪♪
♪♪ فلننساها ولنبني ،
حاضرنا المشرق بثبات ♪♪
♪♪ يكفينا ما اخذته من امال شباب وبنات ♪♪
♪♪ وهبتنا وهما وسبات سلبتنا حتى الكلمات ♪♪
♪♪ سرقت خضرة ماضينا جعلت من ارضنا رفات♪♪
(موسيقى) (آهات)
(موسيقى)
(تصفيق)